morning all plainclothes police officers
could be deployed
to patrol bars and nightclubs all part
of plans to protect women
from predatory offenders extra funding
has been promised to improve
street lighting and cctv further protest
took place in london last night over the
policing bill and of course the met's
response
to saturday's vigil for sarah average on
clapham common
the man charged with her kidnapping
murder is due before the old bailly this
morning
skies and a brady has this morning's
first report
[Music]
this started out as a protest against
the policing bill in parliament
but it quickly turned into a march
against the tactics used by officers
to break up saturday night's vigil in
memory of sarah everard
by the time it ended the government had
doubled the size of its safer streets
fund
aimed at improving lighting and cctv
the prime minister really really wanted
to show that we are listening and that
we want to act
to help women feel safe in our streets
which is why this investment
will go on very practical measures like
increasing better lighting
more cctv to try to give people that
confidence
that we really really want to instill
after last week's terribly
terribly sad event at clapham common
more and more
tributes have been left at the bandstand
just a few streets away
from where sarah was abducted we don't
just need legislation
we need a kind of a uk-wide a worldwide
culture change
so much needs to change the way that we
view women and the way that we respect
women
or the way that we don't respect women
the prime minister says he wants to
drive out violence against women and
girls
and will bring in landmark legislation
to toughen sentences
and put more police on the streets
saturday night's events in fapum are now
the subject of a review by the police
inspectorate
ordered by the home secretary who has
also urged the public not to attend
any further vigils because of the
pandemic
wayne cousins the 48 year old police
officer charged with sarah everard's
murder will appear at the old bailey
later today ender brady sky news
uh let's bring this guy's ali fortescue
who's joining us this morning i'm from
clapham common morning ali um just bring
us up to date with the latest
some news emerging overnight about the
perhaps the suspension the removal of
duties of a serving met officer
yeah that's right so an officer who'd
been working on sarah everard's case
in kent has been referred to the police
watchdog he's been
removed from his duties after allegedly
sharing an inappropriate graphic now
we're not exactly sure what that graphic
was we know that it wasn't
a photograph some reports that we
haven't confirmed in the papers this
morning that this was an inappropriate
meme but clearly
this was serious enough for concerns to
be raised and it to be raised
with the police watchdog and obviously
that is going to
add fuel to the outpouring that we have
seen since
sarah everard's death and this bandstand
has really
become a symbol of solidarity since then
men and women in particular up and down
the country coming here
whether they knew sarah everard or not
to show their respects i'd like to read
you
a couple of the messages that i've seen
uh
here this morning one saying to sarah we
are so sorry this happened to you a
second
saying that i never knew you but we will
spend the rest of our lives
fighting injustice for you and that i
think
says it all really that last message
this has sparked something this has
brought the spot like very firmly
onto women's safety onto policing but of
course at the heart of all of this
is 33 year old sarah everard and it is
now almost two weeks since she
was last seen we know of course that uh
her body was found in a woodland in kent
and as you heard there wayne cousins the
serving police officer will be appearing
at the old bailey today and he of course
is charged with her murder ali thank you
our joint once again on the program by
the foreign secretary dominic rabb mr
app great to see you this morning um
i i wonder though if we can just start
with those at those events
on clapham common at the weekend a few
day on from that vigil
what is your assessment of exactly where
the police
went wrong well look it's a
a very tragic case and we're also
concerned obviously about
uh confidence in the ability
to walk the streets safe at night
particularly obviously for women
that's the number one priority weave in
relation to the way the vigils were
handled by the police
we've got two reviews one by the met
themselves but also
the independent review by her majesty's
inspector of constabulary i think it's
right to allow those to take
place they can do so without fear or
favor and we need to learn the lessons
of it
i do also think it's worth saying the
job the police are doing an incredibly
difficult job at the moment
um and but it's always right to learn
those lessons
i i'm just wondering though you know as
a as a man as a father i believe you've
got boys i mean
you may well have thought the same as me
over the weekend you know i'm kind of
quite glad
this morning that that i don't have a
daughter i just i just wonder what
reflections
you yourself might have had about what
role you i men in our
in our circumstances what role we have
played in
getting the country to a point where you
know 50
of the population practically every one
of them over a certain age
can complain about treatment at the
hands of men
okay i think it's appalling that women
still suffer the fear the intimidation
the threats
and i say that as a son a husband
and uh the brother or sister so
um of course we've all got and i think
the vast majority of men will feel this
uh whilst recognizing that women are the
ones that face the brunt of this
that we've all got stake in society and
we all very personally want to see the
streets
safe for women to walk at night i mean i
feel that very personally and very
piercingly
the key thing i guess from i look at it
as a policy maker and a politician is
what we doing about it
and that's why we're increasing the
number of police by twenty thousand
we've heard new measures
to make the streets safer with cctv and
lighting overnight we've got two bits of
legislation
going through the house of commons to
increase the sentencing i was a
justice minister twice uh i've been
looking at those issues i worked on the
original increase in stalking sentences
but clearly we've got to do more
just in terms of the other the other
legal process that's going on at the
moment the passing of the
the set what the second reading i should
say of the police crime sentencing and
court spell
i mean your colleague charles walker
said yesterday in the commons
this house at the house of commons
criminalized the freedom of protest
this house us not dame cressida not the
metropolitan police we did we
criminalized the freedom to protest
collectively
in his assessment we are up to our
eyeballs in this
where is he wrong it's certainly true
that the house of commons and parliament
as a whole is legislated
to restrict the ability to come together
in gatherings for a temporary period
because of this pandemic which has taken
the lives of so many
and the thorny issue is how we get the
balance right between
peaceful protests expressing our concern
with something as terrible as the sarah
everhard case
whilst also the public protection as we
come through this vicious and deadly
pandemic
and that's just an incredibly inherently
difficult uh
challenge but the measures that we've
taken are temporary
necessary to save lives so of course we
and and the concern would be um if we
made exceptions for one or other however
compelling the case was
is that we would start to see more
widespread
disobedience or non-compliance with the
rules and and then what would that mean
for public health
so that's the the very fine line that
we've got to navigate but i think
overwhelmingly
not withstanding concerns in in this
particular case and they're very serious
which is why we've got two independent
reviews
i think overwhelmingly the police that
you look at the last year
have done a very good and a sensitive
job in policing this pandemic
still still there will be those watching
this morning who wonder
why on earth anyone should listen to to
a conservative politician one who has
served in this government
when it comes to offences of violence
and particularly sexual violence
against women i mean the statistics are
pretty stark in terms of rape cases
to march 2020 58 856 cases of rape were
recorded by police forces in england and
wales
only 1.4 of the rapes recorded
resulted in a charge or a summons i mean
that is failing women
isn't it so what i would say is look at
what we've done we've made it
uh in recent years and i know because i
served as a justice minister
easier for women to report these kinds
of appalling crimes to police
we've also done and i worked on this
again when i was at the
ministry of justice we've made it easier
for them to give evidence in a sensitive
and
a sensitive way as possible within the
court setting
as we've already did all of which would
be laudable if these figures did not
represent the lowest level of
prosecution
since records began whatever you just
whatever
all the measures that you've just
outlined there clearly have not worked
well i
i don't think that's true we've
increased the a number
uh numbers that feel able to report um
but and it depends whether you're
comparing the conviction rate with the
reports or the numbers that are taken to
trial but one of the big challenges
we've got and we're seeking to address
this in every way we can
is getting the evidence where there
isn't uh
there aren't witnesses and so what we've
got to do is work on the technical ways
that we gather that evidence the dna
evidence
making sure it can be presented to
course to court but it is inherently
difficult
in many of these cases where you don't
have third-party witnesses and you don't
have
uh forensic evidence or suggesting it's
not difficult but we're pointing out the
fact that it has got worse and it got
worse
frankly when you were in the justice
department well i i i i
would defend how you're presenting the
figures because of course what we what
we've been more successful
at doing is getting women to report
these crimes which is really important
but that is only and i definitely accept
the first step we then got to be able to
secure convictions but you've got to be
able to do it whilst
also maintaining the integrity of the
justice system and not taking measures
that could risk
miscarriages of justice and that is the
very difficult challenge that i think
uh politicians on all sides politically
have been grappling with and we
we need to work together and do even
better but it is inherently difficult
um can we talk about the integrated
review and of course you will be limited
in what you can say because of the
embargo and the announcement in the
comments
later on today but just just in terms of
some of the detail that
that has emerged i mean are we planning
to increase the number of nuclear
warheads that we hold as a country
well as you rightly sell i need to wait
till it's published to go into the
details but we've always said
we'll tame maintain a minimum credible
deterrence that's
the ultimate insurance policy for the
security of the people in this country
but of course the the integrated review
looks 10 years down the track it's a
generational look at the strategic
approach to foreign policy to defence
we're also looking at the new threats
which is why things like cyber
um how we deal with hostile states the
criminal gangs that are looking to prey
on
our our data our mobile phones our
tablets
and all of those types of threats as
well and what i think is exciting about
review
is it is looking also at our uh our
advantages the assets that we've got the
positives we've got from tech to trade
we've seen it on science with
innovations of the vaccines
how do we marshal all of our hard power
soft power
ingenuity along with our cultural brand
britain is very well regarded abroad how
do we get the most impact
to serve the people of this country from
jobs to security but also to be an even
stronger force for good in the world
which
matters i did just in terms of those of
the threats and the foes that we face
the
the review is said to refer to to russia
as an active threat
china instead is a as a systemic
challenge then we know that lord hager
has in the past talked of
when it comes to china having to be
realists i mean is it your view that we
just have to continue to work with china
despite
the situation the uyghurs for example
the the belligerence that we see
the saber rattling that see with the
chinese well i think there's two
elements first of all we got to be very
clear-sighted
uh china is here to stay it's a
disproportionately large and growing
economic power
we've caused jobs rely on it in this
country we want to continue to trade
um and investment is important but at
the same time we will never do
anything that puts at risk uh the
integrity of our infrastructure our
telecommunications or anything like that
there are other areas where let's face
it if we want to be a a leader in the
world if we want to help
uh bring the the world together to
tackle challenges like climate change
where we're hosting the un talks in
november of course you've got to deal
with china it's the biggest
net emitter it's the biggest investor in
renewable technologies
but there are other areas and you've
talked to action zhang i've been
amongst the leading uh foreign ministers
in the international community standing
up for the people of hong kong
and we will never uh relent or or stop
standing up for other values
including the values of open societies
democracy and human rights
so of course that requires us to take a
calibrated approach if you like to china
but we want a positive relationship
where it's possible but we will never
yield and we will never give up standing
up for our values
um foreign secretary just a little bit
later on today our africa correspondent
john sparks
i'm sure you'll know he will be um we'll
be broadcasting report he has been
inside ethiopia specifically in the in
the tigre region
repeated reports of atrocities there i
just want to play a quick clip
from his report so you can just have a
look at it just a warning uh though that
this clip
does contain some images that people may
all find disturbing let's have a quick
look
what have you seen one three years
thirteen years they killed a 13 year old
child yes
they can i see in my house they told
for the kid come he says come and the
child
go to the solder and kill
by gun and again killed by
in this area you saw that yes i see
in my eye and clearly these are
allegations that need to be put to the
ethiopian authorities
um but i'm just wondering what what
support the british government may well
be ready to provide particularly to
those people who have been displaced
from tigray into
neighboring sudan well look
i'm deeply concerned about this which is
why in january i went to both
ethiopia and sudan i went up to the
gonda region which is where the
humanitarian aid agencies operate entity
grey
i think there's a number of things that
we need to do we first of all as i made
it clear to
the ethiopian government when i was
there we need to see unfettered access
for humanitarian purposes into de grey
so we get some proper
facts uh that we can verify but also so
we can support
uh the vulnerable and there's a risk of
famine as well as the
human rights abuses that your
correspondent was looking into
we've also got to galvanize the
international community so in february
when we held the presidency of the
security council we had the first
discussion
uh if you like i think that there's been
on the situation to grey
under our auspices and of course the aid
and the humanitarian relief we provide
is very important
so we're looking at this in the round we
have a long-standing relationship with
ethiopia
uh probably like me you'll remember
growing up with the
the the famine and the drought and the
uh
and all of those scenes ethiopia has
come a long way since then
we're very worried that it will lose
some of those hard-won gains we'll do
everything we can
to stop that dominic rabb good to see
you this morning thanks for being with
us
please let's bring in our political
correspondent tom rayner who was out
listening to our discussion with mr wrap
what left out to you
well i think on the issues that have
been raised
in the wake of the killing of sarah
everard
what is clear is the government are
determined to try and show
that they are doing things the foreign
secretary was keen to point out that an
extra 20 million was committed last
night following that meeting of the
crime and justice task force to making
streets safer he said it is the
overriding objective to make women feel
safer
on the streets but you pushed him on the
question of the government's record on
all of this
on the number of rape prosecutions very
stark numbers that you set out and he
said that the government had
uh done work to make it easier for women
to report
these kind of appalling crimes as he put
it and easier to give evidence
in as sensitive a way as possible
pointed as well to the fact that there
are these two
pieces of legislation going through the
house of commons but clearly this is an
issue where
the government recognize the challenges
but
there will be no doubt further criticism
from the opposition that the legislation
doesn't go far enough it focuses on
uh some of the wrong things and i think
they're going to be ongoing questions
just also interestingly neil just
quickly on that issue of
um the ability to demonstrate to hold
protests i think what we heard from
dominic raab
went a bit further than we've heard from
the volunteer
from the home secretary or the prime
minister because he articulated why
the government do still want the police
to
deal with demonstrations and protests he
said because
if you don't if they hadn't if the
police hadn't been marshalling what was
going on
on clapham common you have the potential
to set a precedent and he said then you
could see wider disobedience
which given the pandemic could see a
wider impact on public health we've not
heard that
argument set out before tom thanks very
much indeed
uh well let's turn back to that aspect
of our interview with
the foreign secretary where we dealt
with the integrated review
tom you can leave i can speak to our
foreign affairs editor debra haynes for
a little bit more on that um deborah
just in terms of well we didn't get very
much from the foreign secretary an
embargoed announcement it's a statement
to the commons later
but we should be in no doubt i mean this
is going to set the tone
for our foreign policy for our defence
policy for quite some time
yes absolutely there's going to be a lot
more detail coming out
um later on this morning and this
integrated review is is being billed as
the biggest shape-up
of shakeup rather of british
foreign defense security development
policy since the cold war
and i think there's three key areas that
would be interesting to look at
and the foreign secretary did touch on
all of them in the comments that he just
made to you
um the first is that fundamental issue
about
values uh we we believe we believe that
the review will talk about china
as being a a a a sort of
a challenge a systemic challenge um and
russia as being an active threat um and
that really kind of talks to how the
government really has to
um deal with the balancing act of china
is a reality as the foreign secretary
secretary said it's a growing power it's
here to stay
and clearly the the the values that
china upholds it's an authoritarian
regime
are very much different to the ones an
open democracy like the uk has
so you'll see this review being all
about the uk trying to galvanize
like-minded countries build on alliances
help to shape
a future that will see a multilateral
international system an open
international order
as opposed to a return to some kind of
new cold war that some people have
talked about
a time where the world is very much
divided
along two different opposing sides
that's something that the uk
does want to avoid whether it can or not
obviously remains to be seen
the other area you touched on is that
nuclear weapons
which is part of the hard power that the
uk
is clearly wanting to demonstrate while
it's not a superpower anymore by any
stretch
it it is a it is a middle strong power
as well so
building up on its military it's got a
huge increase in defense spending
and then finally the last point to make
is about technology and the sec
the foreign secretary talked about that
too britain clearly sees itself as a
wants to be a science and technology
superpower so we'll have more about that
too
busy day for you ahead bro for now
thanks very much indeed
uh plenty more coming up on this show in
fact uh labour's jess phillips
will be joining us shortly we'll be
discussing the new policing bill
as labour analysis show that women made
up more than
half the victims of all violent crime in
the last three years
after eight i'll be speaking to an
epidemiologist about whether those
safety concerns being expressed in parts
of europe about the
az vaccine are unfounded
and the wartime love letters found under
the floorboards
of a scarborough hotel will be speaking
to the hotel's manager
and a historian about this astonishing
discovery
coming your way
england's new children's commissioner
has told sky news that improving the
lives of children in
care is the absolute top priority dame
rachel d'souza says
she'll be fearless in holding the
government to account
over its promises to improve the
experiences
of looked after children are people in
politics correspondent nick martin has
this report
which one was it it is
this one here that bottom window was my
bedroom window
i lived there when i was 16 for a couple
of months
so this is it here yeah and what do you
remember about being here
even like looking at it is making me
anxious really
taylor dawson has spent his teenage
years in care
and he says it's left him traumatized
how are you feeling
really really anxious it's just i've not
been here
since i lived here so it's a bit weird
yeah i just remember being terrified all
the time
just never knowing what to expect the
next day
he's one of 80 000 looked after children
in england
just over 10 000 are in residential care
taylor says his mental health has
suffered ever since
i felt like people didn't care about me
and i felt completely worthless and
a lot of that is because of the way i
was treated by the social care system
taylor's residential placement was
unregulated that means it's not
inspected by ofsted like a children's
home is
from september the government will ban
unregulated homes for under 16s
but not for 16 and 17 year olds the
department for education has told us it
wants placements for this age group
to adhere to national standards in the
future overseen by ofsted
but there's a crucial difference here
there is a reason why the government is
talking about standards
rather than regulation and that's cost
regulated
children's homes can charge local
authorities more money
at a time when councils say they can't
afford it
this is dame rachel de souza she's
england's latest
children's commissioner do you think the
government were wrong
to not go far enough to ban unregulated
accommodation for under 18 year olds
were they wrong to do that what i would
say is
good start right good start you've
sorted out naught to 16.
now she did not adjust let's work on
work on taking the next step
um and i think we need to be showing
them
and showing them why that's 16 to 18
really do we need to show them
why we we we know the impact that
unregulated accommodation has on
children under 18.
we know the risks that it poses the
government knew that
were they wrong to not go that far
clearly we need to show them more
i was a child and yes i was an older
child
but i was still a kid and i deserved
better i deserved to be looked
this after an independent review has
begun to look at children's social care
it'll look at why thousands of children
are still living in homes that aren't
regulated
to ask whether the government should ban
this accommodation
for all children under 18. nick martin
sky news
and you can watch nick's special full
report at lost in care that's throughout
the day the times
listed here next up half past three this
afternoon
and if you've been affected by time and
care you can contact
become now that's the national charity
for children in care and
young care leavers their phone number or
800 023
2033 or you can visit
www.becomecharity.org
dot uk uk and you can also of course
uh speak to the samaritans if you find
yourself affected by
issues in that report you can contact
them their phone number
one one six one two three the email
joejo
samaritans.org a couple more of the
stories making the news this morning
uh let's turn our attention to europe
where the medicines watchdog will meet
today to discuss the
safety of the astrazeneca vaccine after
several eu member states halted roll
outs due to concerns over blood clots
germany france italy spain will have
joined smaller nations in halting
vaccinations
as a precaution whilst further checks
are made the world health organization
has urged countries
not to suspend the rollouts insisting
the vaccine is
safe to be used the head of the uk
environment agency is warning that
driving missions down to net zero will
not be enough to properly combat the
climate emergency
so james bevin is urging businesses to
take what he calls
a net zero plus approach by adapting to
the impacts of
global warming
and labour is calling on the government
to end the outsourcing
of contact tracing in england to large
private companies
the party has written to the health
secretary matt hancock urging him to
integrate coronavirus testing into local
public health teams
all this following a report by the
public accounts committee
which found there was no clear evidence
that the
test and trace system helped to reduce
cases
despite of course a 22 billion pound
budget
uh time to see how the weather is
looking this tuesday
at nas is standing by the screen with
the details morning nice
good morning it's looking increasingly
sunny and drier for this afternoon for
most places but this morning
it is a bit cloudy and damp out there
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies the
weather
sponsored by qatar airways
good morning we're going to see
increasing amounts of
spring warmth develop across many parts
of the uk island for the rest of this
weekend some good spells of sunshine and
largely dry conditions but
down towards parts of the southeast it
could turn colder into the weekend
until then it's cloudy and wet this
morning across large amounts of england
and whale spells of rain across the
north and west and down towards
eastern parts as well but elsewhere it's
already become much dry and brighter
after a cloudy and damp start and by
midday ireland northern ireland
scotland the north and west of england
and wales will be seeing
sunshine and dry conditions and
eventually the rest of england will
become dry and brighter too but
east anglia and the southeast will take
some time to become drier as that cloud
rain and drizzle move south eastwards
eastern coastal areas a breezy cool day
but mild elsewhere
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
nice thank you uh still to come on the
program this morning and
vaccine safety experts from the world
health organization
are set to review the oxford azad jab as
several european countries
hope they'll roll out we're discussing
that next
[Music]
[Music]
i've been pretty good at it got out of
practice do you think you have the
energy to match donald trump
i have more energy than all of them i
may be the first woman in this office
i will not be the last
[Applause]
[Music]
i'm cordelia lynch and i'm skye's u.s
correspondent based in washington
[Music]
america is a complex place and we've got
to show them
i've witnessed deep loss in america deep
division and deep bravery how you doing
sir
everyone here is being intubated and the
chance of survival
is very slim there are parts of this
city that look
apocalyptic they are a symbol of deep
anger
made for people who want clarity in an
uncertain world
we're about an hour outside of the
capital and you can see
a young man's body just there four
friends
four friends killed
once y'all leave they kill you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back further protest took place
last night in london
against the metropolitan police's
response to the vigil for sarah everard
and clapham over the weekend and of
course against the government's crime
policing and sentencing
bill going through the house at the
moment designed to give the police new
expanded powers
to tackle protests within the past few
minutes the foreign secretary told me
that the
lessons from the investigation into the
met's conduct
must be learned but that the difficulty
of the police's job
should also be taken into account well
look it's a very tragic case and we're
also concerned obviously about
confidence in the ability to walk the
street safe at night particularly
obviously for women
that's the number one priority weave in
relation to the way the vigils were
handled by the police
we've got two reviews one by the met
themselves but also
the independent review by her majesty's
inspector of constabulary i think it's
right to allow those to take place they
can do so
without fear or favor and we need to
learn the lessons of it i do also think
it's worth saying that
the police are doing an incredibly
difficult job at the moment
and but it's always right to learn those
lessons
ah let's speak to labour's shadow
minister for domestic violence and
safeguarding
jess phillips phillips great to have you
in the programme this morning and
i i wonder if we might start with that
which we just had from dominic graham
do you understand that no matter what
anyone thinks about what happened
on clapham common at the weekend the the
the police have had a very difficult
job particularly over the course of a
pandemic to
to police demonstrations to police
vigils
i mean totally i totally agree with that
and you know what i'm not in the
business of is trying to
pitch the police against the public and
i think that they've been left in a very
difficult position and i think that
we all have to consider um how that's
been allowed to happen and actually
some of the the the way that the police
have been left with
certain discretion about certain things
is actually the fault of politicians
um and we've got to look at that as we
go forward and legislate in the future
to make sure that we don't make this
mistake again
i think the metropolitan police made the
wrong turn in lots of cases
over the weekend but i i don't
underestimate the the the difficulty
that police forces have with their new
covered regulations
um and what is being proposed in
parliament this week
with new protest bills and i think that
that leaves them as exposed
as they have been this weekend i mean to
your credit you have been one of those
politicians who have been laying bare
the
the problems that women have been
experiencing up and down this country
for
for quite some time now but the labour
party and you yourself have
done even more of a deep dive into the
statistics and we're finding out even
more about
the the way in which women have
experienced negative impacts
from from violent and sexually violent
predatory offending
yeah absolutely and i think that i think
that what goals me
so much about um
i mean if it was possible to be annoyed
more than i am already about violence
against women and girls more generally
but what annoys me i think about the
government's response um
over well whether that was last night or
uh
in the bill that is before us in
parliament is that it simply
has forgotten the experiences of women
and one of the main
problems that we have of politicians
like me
who have been trying to you know
highlight for years as i read out the
names of women who have
been murdered at the hands of violent
men every year i do that because i
i want people to understand the sheer
scale
the sheer volume about how when we talk
about keeping our
country safe and politicians like boris
johnson stand in front of podiums
and talk about national security that
they've got to be talking about the
women in this country
who are largely not safe on the streets
almost every woman has a story to tell
women 2.3 million women
are suffering from domestic violence so
they're not safe at home
and the metoo movement before this
outpouring showed us
how difficult it can be for women at
work so when we're talking about
security
i would just ask the government not to
forget us and the bill that i
am being asked to vote on in parliament
today
has nothing it's about policing and
crime that's the title of the bill well
to me it's an abuser's charter because
it does
more to silence my voice when i want to
protest
about these things than it does to
protect me there is nothing about raping
it there is
nothing about domestic abuse there is
nothing about street harassment
and i can't believe that the government
would put forward a piece of legislation
about crime
and justice while rape statistics are as
they are in our country and
falling and not to put something in
there about improving
rape conviction rates that would stop
the last year 55
000 rape referrals 1
800 people were convicted
i mean it is it is when you put it in
those terms and we put it in those terms
to the foreign secretary this morning
you know it it is quite it is quite
staggering
but but as as kirsten himself said in a
report running overnight you know this
bill could have been the vehicle to
address some of these long-standing
issues
i was dpp for five years these issues
were there then this is not new
i mean i i just do wonder whether or not
you know the guy who is
the leader of the official of her
majesty's official opposition could have
actually done more
when he was director of public
prosecutions
uh you've got to remember that while uh
kiestarmo was the dpp i was working in a
rape crisis center so we were offered
our paths
often crossing of course uh like i would
with any dpp
uh we had robust asks but i have to say
uh that while kirsten was the dpp he did
huge amounts to try and improve the
court experience
the evidence gathering and the way that
we handle uh
rate cases no this is a difficult issue
it needs a fundamental shift by
politicians actually
that we hand down to civil servants like
those who are running our crown
prosecution service
but we have done nothing but tinker
around the edges for far too long
and what is more in the last 10 years uh
the the degradation
of police forces of specialist sexual
uh violence units in police forces we
call them rassos
um they i i asked the government
recently whether they
where they were across the country and
which forces had them and the answer is
i don't know the data
so that isn't a good enough answer the
government should be able to confidently
come back at me and say
every police force in this country has a
specialist
sexual violence unit that will deal with
rape and sexual violence
and until that is the case i'm going to
keep on getting on their backs
what would be the biggest single change
that the government could make in the
wake of
what we've seen over the past few days
to to protect
women and girls when when they're doing
nothing more
that than going out for an evening i
mean we've had about extra millions
being put in
to perhaps expand cctv in one of the
most surveilled nations in the western
world we've heard
uh talk about using undercover officers
in clubs and bars
you know which presumably they could do
right now if they wanted to
what one major policy step forward would
you want them to see from the government
i mean i i i wish that i i it could be
uh distilled down
uh if you if you were to push me i would
say well first of all we have to make it
illegal
to harass um and follow and aggressively
pursue women on
the the streets and that isn't what came
out of
yesterday's meeting what came out of the
meeting that the prime minister had
yesterday was around cctv which of
course has been degraded over the past
10 years
my constituents always want to see more
cctv so i'm not going to say there's
anything wrong with it
no victim of crime or specialist victims
agency i'd ever worked with
who proposed it's the solution so i
don't know where the prime minister's
getting that information from
but the undercover police officers i
have to say i think that has not been
thought through
um and what i don't understand is if
these undercover police officers find
somebody they go and report it to
a uniform police officer we're relying
on having huge amounts of people at
police on our streets in this instance
which
i don't know if you've been out in town
like recently but you don't see huge
numbers of police
so the the reality is is but what crime
is the uniform police officer then going
to charge
somebody with because it isn't a crime
to harass somebody in the public realm
so i don't if i had to pick one first of
all i'd make it a crime
and then i'd see about what resources
needed to be put into it because
at the moment we're going to have cctv
capturing footage of something that then
can't be reported or charged as anything
so good good try prime minister in your
meeting i offered to come to the meeting
i know other feminist uh organizations
and women's organizations and
rape crisis organizations and experts
offered as well um
so i'm not sure where they've come to
this but i'm more than happy for this to
be a day one step and to work with them
to make this better
jess phillips good to see you this
morning thanks for being with us
now kim jong-un's sister has warned the
united states not to cause a stink
as its president prepares to set out his
policy on
north korea speaking on state media
state media
kim yo-jong criticized the u.s and south
korea
for conducting joint military exercises
uh let's speak to our asia correspondent
uh tom cheshire
joining us from beijing morning tom um
is this just the usual saber rattling we
see from the north koreans
yeah we haven't seen much of that sabre
rattling for a bit really it's been very
quiet from north korea after
you'll remember of course the huge uh
pageantry of those summits between kim
jong-un
and president donald trump uh after that
all went south north korea was launching
some small missiles but nothing major
and since president biden uh won the
election and took
office we haven't heard anything from
that and that's despite
the us saying it has been reaching out
since mid-february through several
channels but hasn't had a response
from north korea while they've probably
been spending that time working on this
singer from kim yo jong kim jong-un's
sister
she said we take this opportunity to
warn the new u.s administration
which is trying hard to give off the
powder smell in our land
if he wants to sleep in peace for the
coming four years it had better refrain
from causing a stink at its first step
those war games are going on
as you mentioned they're actually
digital war games this year but with
with south korea and the us because of
corona
virus restrictions but it's also as the
u.s secretaries of
state and defense are flying to asia to
japan and south korea in particular to
talk about relations uh
the north korea is reminding everyone we
are in this region and we're still
a very very important part of this
region there'd been a lot of focus of
course on
china and how president biden was going
to deal with china but north korea has
been a problem for
every american president in the days of
kim jong-il as well as kim
jong-un north korea is still a nuclear
power it is going to be a headache for
biden
and he's going to have to work out what
his approach is going to be in dealing
with them
tom many thanks still to come on the
program this morning
as mps prepare to vote on the policing
bill
we'll be talking to a human rights
lawyer about what it means for protests
journalism is under attack he's clearly
marked as a press
the right has actually been declared you
have to have the facts
i will stand in the way of the enemy you
have to have the evidence on camera
because people are doubting everything
you are further pushing the agenda that
is condemning all of us
to prove her wrong to expose corruption
to show the truth i don't think any
journalist wants anything more than that
[Music]
so
[Music]
the wind was like pulling us out of that
little room
[Music]
mandatory evacuation you must leave
i'm greg milam skye's u.s correspondent
here in los angeles
it is almost impossible to predict where
these fires will go next
we aim to be the best and most trusted
place for news
[Music]
this gives you an idea of the strength
of those wins strong enough to bend
and twist metal
are you trying to run me over to philip
no go away look like it sir
will you respond to those who've made
accusations so philip can you go away
i've seen the dark side of america
we are standing on the supply line right
into the heart
of america's opioid crisis
[Music]
i've seen heartbreaking human stories
there was a river of blood coming out of
the mosque that's a scene that you don't
forget christ church has been changed
forever by what happened
[Music]
for the early risers
for the knowledge seekers
for the straight talkers the curious and
the ones who want to be entertained
backstage sky news entertainment podcast
but wherever you are welcome to
safety rage what's monday podcast for
the ones who want to know more welcome
to the all-out politics podcast
for the listeners from sky news
sky news podcasts listen and subscribe
for free did you know that air pollution
isn't just bad for the environment it's
bad for our health too
[Music]
after a rather cloudy and wet morning
most places will see sunshine
and largely dry conditions develop from
the west however eastern england will
remain cloudy
with outbreaks of light rain and drizzle
for most of the day particularly in the
southeast although it will eventually
become drier and brighter there
so taking a look at the air pollution
levels on a scale of 1 to 10
with 10 being very high most places will
be at a low level of 1 to 3 again
thanks to air originating from the
atlantic
the air quality report sponsored by
phillips air purifiers
mps will this evening vote on the
controversial police crime
sentencing and courts bill with concerns
raised on how the legislation could
affect
the public's right to protest labor has
already announced it will oppose
the legislation calling it
disproportionate
uh joining us on the programme to
explain a little bit more about all of
this the human rights banister
adam wagner adam great to see you this
morning um
before we move on to the to the policing
bill i just wonder if we can
kind of dwell on events and on clapping
common at
the weekend and just in terms of what
the police did now they say that they
had to act because
officers felt that the gathering had
become unlawful
what is your assessment of that
well um i was acting for reclaim these
streets the um
the organization that was organizing the
the
vigils on thursday and friday and
basically the metropolitan police
refused to engage
and work with the organizers and i think
what ended up happening is that
because the organizers of reclaim these
streets had to pull out
on friday evening after the met police
said they wouldn't
work with them instead of this being a
covert safe vigil with covert marshals
with
uh qr code scanning to make sure they
could um
trace people with staggered entry it
ended up being well
you can see the pictures on the screen
and obviously you don't know what's
going to happen
um in all circumstances but i think it
would have been a lot safer and a lot
less likely to get out of control
if the police had recognized that there
is still a right to protest there is
still a right to freedom of speech
and that and and it's necessary
sometimes for them to work with
organizers rather than working against
them
um adam talked to us then about the the
police crime sentencing and
and courts built second reading uh today
i mean for the for the government's part
they say that a lot of it is a direct
response to
some of the protests that we've seen
over the past couple of years black
lives matter but perhaps more
particularly
extinction rebellion on that basis there
might be quite a lot of people in and
around central london in particular
that might think it no bad thing
yeah well i mean there's always going to
be people who think that it's no bad
thing to stop protests they don't agree
with
and and that really goes to the heart of
why it's so
risky to give police powers to prevent
protests because ultimately they end up
preventing the protests
that they disagree with and we saw a
really good example of the weekend that
there was
yeah that was a protest that
significantly involved the metropolitan
police themselves
because of what happened with sarah
everett and i'm not saying the police
were
were deciding to to prevent it because
it was against them but it just goes to
show that the police
shouldn't be responsible for these
things and i think that the danger of
the new
um bill is that it makes it a lot easier
a lot easier for
police to control and prevent protests
because effectively
we go from a situation where they can
oppose directions
on protests where there will be serious
disruption to the community
or intimidation to um where it would be
just
very noisy i mean that's quite literally
what the
the bill is is that if there's a um
if if there's enough noise from the
protest to cause serious unease
alarm or distress to bystanders uh sorry
to bystanders then the
police can impose conditions and if a
person breaches a condition
if they ought to have known that it was
enforced then they
they're in line for criminal penalties
and that will
you know if the police use these powers
and inevitably police do
use these powers when they're under
pressure from the public then
that will effectively prevent a
significant number of protests happening
and that is bad for
i think you know people might find
protests annoying that the point of
protest is they get people's attention
sometimes they are annoying sometimes
they are noisy in fact it wouldn't be
much for a protest if it wasn't noisy
but they are fundamental to our
democracy just in the same way that
parliament is in the same way that the
courts
are and we have to be very careful
before we limit them
indeed so but in terms of the this bill
itself and
you can clear this one up for me doesn't
the home secretary have quite a big role
in terms through secondary legislation
providing examples of of what would
count as
too noisy doesn't doesn't the home
secretary have whoever he or she may be
at the time of a protest
have the ability to be called in by the
police and and say well
this can happen this can't happen
there's a there's a degree of
responsibility that goes directly
to the person in charge of policing
isn't that
yeah i mean there's there's a there's a
big risk there's a there's a big power
it's not a responsibility it's a power
for the home secretary to make
regulations and we've seen this with the
covid
laws that um the all the covert laws
have come in through regulations and
what that means for people who don't
follow the intricacies of parliamentary
procedure is that instead of having to
go through
parliament and be voted on by and you
know debated voted on amended all that
kind of stuff
they just get to be signed by the home
secretary and maybe there'll be a vote
in parliament
um at some point but it's a it's a it's
a very very truncated parliamentary
procedure and what that means is
that the home secretary has a very
significant amount of power
to impose um her or his
perspective on what is and what isn't
a lawful protest and again that really
funnels
all the power or much of the power to
the home secretary
and to the police and and and i i would
ask the public this if you have a cause
that you deeply care about and think of
that cause what it is now
um if you wanted to go out one day to
protest about that do you want the home
secretary and the police to have the
ultimate say
in whether what you're saying is right
or wrong and whether you can do that or
not
um and i think most people would say i'm
so sorry we we we do have to leave it
there we're just out of time i have
we'll see what amendments might come
from the committee stage adam wagner
good to see you thanks for joining us